Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 24. Heute unser Thema Computer und Blinde, Blinde und Computer zu Gast Sebastian Andres und der Mikrofon Tim Pritlove.
Ja.
Ja, Respekt for the DJs, Respekt for der Musik. Ich hab in letzter Zeit vergessen, die Musik mal vorzustellen, auch wenn ich mich ein bisschen wiederhole. Immer noch wähle ich sehr gerne die Musik aus dem Zerinnerung DJ-Mix-Net-Label aus, weil da immer so schön regelmäßig was kommt und weil die Musik vor allem frei ist. Creative Commons-Musik, die man beliebig verwenden kann, also natürlich nicht total beliebig, aber auf jeden Fall in einem nicht-kommerziellen Rahmen, ziemlich unbegrenzt, ohne Leute fragen zu müssen. Das ist der Vorteil dieser Lizenz. Aber das soll heute das Thema nicht sein, sondern das Thema ist ein anderes. Dazu begrüße ich erstmal Sebastian. Hallo Sebastian.
Ja, hallo.
Hör vorrangig. Ja, wir hatten schon längere Zeit im Gespräch, mal diesen Podcast zu machen. Ich bin froh, dass wir jetzt endlich die Zeit gefunden haben, das auch mal zu tun. Du warst ja schon auf dem 22C3, auf dem Kongress mit dabei und hast dort einen Vortrag gegeben. Der Titel, was denn noch?
Ja, ich glaube, das war Barrierefreies Linux und da hatten wir den Schwerpunkt gesetzt auf Blinde und Sehbehinderte. Ich hatte das mit dem Lars Stetten zusammen gemacht vom Linaccess-Team.
An der Stelle kann ich natürlich auch gleich freudestrahlend verkünden, dass die Videoaufzeichnungen von dem Kongress, unter anderem auch von diesem Vortrag, jetzt endlich verfügbar sind. Wir hatten da einige Probleme, da natürlich mal wieder, trotz allerbester Vorbereitung, das eine oder andere Seil gerissen ist mit dem Ergebnis, dass wir dann sehr viel von Hand wieder herstellen mussten. Das ist jetzt nach längerer Arbeit endlich geglückt und die Dateien liegen alle zum Download bereit. Die Serverleitungen glühen schon. Heute, wo wir das aufnehmen, verteilen wir das nur per BitTorrent für eine Weile, bis wir uns leisten können, da unsere Server den direkten HTTP-Zugriff auszusetzen. Aber es gibt jetzt schon zahlreiche Mirrors und ihr solltet Mittel und Wege finden, diese Veranstaltungen, die Aufzeichnung, Videoaufzeichnung, runterzuladen. Demnächst dann auch noch die Audiovarianten und sobald ich dazu gekommen bin und noch ein paar Konvertierungsläufe durchgelaufen sind, gibt es das Ganze dann auch als Podcast. Ja, so viel zu dem Thema. Aber zurück zu dir, Sebastian. Wir haben es schon anklinken lassen. Du bist blind und beschäftigst dich mit Computern. Bist auch selber Student der Informatik, ist das richtig? Ja. Wo studierst du?
Hier in Berlin an der FU. Ich bin jetzt im zweiten Semester.
Was hat dich dazu gebracht, das Studium aufzunehmen?
Im Allgemeinen habe ich mich schon relativ früh, also für meine Verhältnisse früh, denke ich, mit Computern beschäftigt und mal mehr, mal weniger. Und habe dann auch, als es dann die Möglichkeit gab, unter Windows was zu machen, das ist ja nun für blinde Menschen eigentlich leider, muss man sagen, immer noch die erste Anlaufstelle. Und ich dann gemerkt habe, was eigentlich so möglich ist, was man so alles machen kann. Und dann hat mich auch mehr die Technik dahinter interessiert. Wie funktioniert das jetzt? Was passiert da eigentlich im Hintergrund? Oder wo kann ich noch was verändern? Und ja, so bin ich dann einfach zu dem Studium gekommen.
Und selber deine Interessenlage, wie würdest du das so beschreiben? Was interessiert dich am meisten?
Ja, also am meisten im Moment fasziniert mich eigentlich im allgemeinen Netzwerktechnik. Und ja, was man da alles so machen kann und wie weitläufig das ist. Und na ja gut, so ein Spezialgebiet in dem Sinne, würde ich sagen, habe ich im Moment noch nicht. Aber ja, wie gesagt, Interesse in Netzwerkbereichen und Skript ein bisschen, aber eigentlich eher weniger.
Ja, was mich halt mal so zu Beginn interessieren würde, ist, wo ziehst du jetzt persönlich? Den Nutzen aus dem Computer? Und wo ziehst du auch den Nutzen aus dem Internet in dem Zusammenhang?
Ja, das ist natürlich ein sehr vielfältiger Bereich. Das Internet bietet Mittel und Wege, die es so für mich gar nicht gäbe. Also das fängt an bei irgendwelchen Shoppingportalen, sei es Amazon oder eBay oder was auch immer. Und ja, Homebanking ist ein Schwerpunkt für mich, weil das sind gerade Punkte, da bräuchte ich ansonsten Hilfe, wenn ich die selber nicht ausfüllen kann, wenn ich des Sehens nicht mächtig bin. Und da brauche ich Alternativen. Und da ist dann halt eine Alternative durchaus das Internet, weil ich das relativ problemlos und relativ barrierefrei benutzen kann. Und das ist ein erheblicher Vorteil.
Und Amazon und so, die schicken das zu. Wie ist das so mit dem Regionaleinkauf? Supermärkte, gibt es da auch schon Erleichterungen?
Ja, zumindest in dem Sinne, dass man die Angebote der Supermärkte, sei es Aldi oder Lidl oder Edeka oder was man halt auch so kennt, zumindest kann man dort die Angebote per E-Mail abonnieren. Das ist zumindest schon mal eine kleine Hilfestellung, dass man schon mal im Vorhinein weiß, was es da eigentlich so billig gibt.
Aldi verschickt seine Preislisten per E-Mail?
Nicht die ganzen Preislisten, sondern was sie halt im Angebot haben. Also wenn es jetzt einen neuen Computer gibt, zum Beispiel, dann kann man das direkt dort sehen und ist eigentlich auch sehr gut gemacht, weil das auch eigentlich recht detailliert beschrieben ist. Also man sieht auch, man steht auch schon bei, was im Computer eigentlich an Hardware enthalten ist.
Und gut, ich meine, das sind ja jetzt alles Angebote, die auch jeder andere benutzt. Gibt es denn auch spezielle Angebote, die sich jetzt mehr oder weniger auf Blinde zugeschnitten sind, die du nutzt, die für dich interessant sind?
Da wüsste ich jetzt eigentlich so nichts. Also kann man so, glaube ich, gar nicht sagen. Also zum Beispiel jetzt bei einer einen Bank, wo ich im Moment mein Homebanking mache, die eine Bank hat ein extra barrierefreies Bankingportal geschaffen. Nun weiß ich nicht, ob man das so weit zählen kann und sagen kann, okay, das ist jetzt für Blinde, was nicht unbedingt gedacht ist. Weil dieses Portal war genauso für Handy-Benutzer gedacht wie auch für Blinde, die halt einfach textuell mehr arbeiten und nicht unbedingt die letzte Grafik sehen wollen und müssen. Und das denke ich. Ansonsten wüsste ich jetzt so spontan eigentlich nichts. Wobei ich noch mal kurz sagen würde, also was auch jeder andere benutzen kann, das hört sich immer so selbstverständlich an. Aber das ist für mich halt gerade eine besondere Errungenschaft, weil ich sonst immer auf Hilfe von anderen Menschen angewiesen bin, die ich in dem Fall nicht unbedingt habe und sonst nicht brauche. Und zum Beispiel, weiß ich, Fahrkarten kaufen bei der Bahn oder so, das nutzen viele meines Wissens. Aber das ist halt einfach eine erhebliche Erleichterung für mich.
Ja, für mich auch. Ja gut, wenn es dann mal funktioniert, dann muss man halt nicht an der Schlange stehen. Das stimmt. Das ist auch wirklich überhaupt nicht zumutbar, also weder für Blinde noch für Nicht-Blinde.
Ja, zumindestens diese komischen Abgrenzungen bei der Bahn, wenn man sich nicht falsch anstellt, dann kommt man nicht hin und das ist alles so eine Sache.
Wobei ich da über die Bahn-Webseite auch noch das eine oder andere Wort verlieren könnte.
Aber seitdem jetzt ein paar Tagen das Portal neu ist, ist es schon besser geworden.
Ach, hat sich da gerade was getan?
Ja, die haben ein neues Portal gemacht, meines Wissens. Also zumindestens die letzte Verkade, die ich hier nach Berlin gebucht habe, ließ ich ein bisschen einfacher buchen, weil sie halt ein anderes Portal hatten. Das fand ich schon ein bisschen barrierefrei. Man könnte zwar noch mehr dran gestalten, aber es war ein richtiger Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Und jetzt solche Sachen wie Amazon und Ebay, wie benutzbar findest du das aus deiner Perspektive?
Ja, also, nun, da ist halt von Barrierefreiheit noch nicht so viel zu sehen. Da muss ich auch ehrlich sagen, es kommt halt auch immer drauf an, es ist noch mal ein erheblicher Unterschied, surfe ich jetzt unter Linux oder surfe ich jetzt unter Windows. Das ist einfach so, dass unter Windows die Screenreader wesentlich noch wesentlich angepasster sind wie unter Linux. Das ist einfach, weil man da eine andere Technik verwendet und so weiter. Und es ist auch einfach so, dass wenn ich zum Beispiel Webseiten habe, die unter Links oder LYNX nicht dargestellt werden können, gibt es trotzdem noch die Möglichkeit, dass ich im Windows, auch wenn ich das ungern mache und auch wenn das eigentlich traurig ist, aber mit dem IE die Seiten trotzdem noch relativ problemlos dann benutzen kann. Und so benutze ich eigentlich das eBay- oder Amazon-Portal meistens unter Windows, weil das unter Linux doch schon relativ schwierig ist. Barrierefreiheit ist ja eigentlich nicht nur von wegen JavaScript raus und alle Images, die man so auf die Seite setzt, beschriften, sondern das hat ja auch noch was mit der Anordnung zu tun und dem Seitenaufbau und der Formatierung an sich und wo steht was und so weiter. Das ist ja noch ein bisschen komplizierter, wie so einfach.
Da sollten wir gleich noch mal auch ein bisschen mehr zu verlieren. Jetzt hast du erwähnt Screenreader. Das wollte ich noch mal kurz vorher noch erklären für die Leute, die nicht wissen, was das ist. Screenreader ist eine Software, die einem den Inhalt vorliest. Aber jetzt reden wir auch wirklich von Sprachausgabe?
Ja, nicht nur. Ein Screenreader, vielleicht soll ich das dann erklären? Screenreader ist eigentlich mehr eine Software, die erst mal Daten aufbereitet. Die nimmt jetzt einfach mal die Daten, die normal an den Bildschirm kommen. Unter Windows geht es sogar so weit, dass der Screenreader einen eigenen virtuellen Grafiktreiber benutzt. Da sieht man mal ganz deutlich, wie systemtiefgreifend das auch unter Umständen sein kann. Mit der virtuellen Grafikkarte werden die Daten konkret an der Grafikkarte abgegriffen und werden dann aufbereitet. Also Bilder rausgenommen, die Texte sogar umformatiert. Also ich habe das mal gezeigt auf einem Vortrag, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht mehr, ich glaube, der war in der B-Look. Da habe ich konkret gezeigt, wie die Seite, wenn eine Webseite mit einem Screenreader unter Windows dargestellt wird und wie sie unter Linux aussieht. Also das sind Unterschiede wie Tag und Nacht. Man erkennt sie eigentlich nicht wieder, obwohl es die gleiche Seite ist.
Aber für dich ist es dann einfacher?
Ja, also einfacher weiß ich nicht. Ich habe mich jetzt daran gewöhnt, weil ich schon Jahre her unter Windows gearbeitet habe. Und unter Linux werden die Seiten so dargestellt, wie sie im Links dargestellt werden. Der Screenreader formatiert da nicht so unbedingt viel um. Und ob das jetzt positiv oder negativ ist, das sei jetzt erstmal dahingestellt, das kann man so auch, glaube ich, gar nicht sagen. Aber jedenfalls, wenn die Seiten dann aufbereitet wurden oder überhaupt die Daten aufbereitet wurden, dann schickt der Screenreader das entweder an eine Sprachausgabe oder an eine Prellzeile oder halt an beides. Es ist halt so, dass die Sprachausgabe in den Screenreader oft integriert ist. Und dass man nicht unbedingt jetzt sagen kann, okay, der Screenreader geht bis zu diesem Punkt und nicht weiter. Die Sprachausgabe ist halt so integriert und der Prelltreiber genauso. Das ganze Teil nennt man dann Screenreader. Aber eigentlich ist das so, dass der Screenreader lediglich die Daten aufbereitet und dann entsprechend an die einzelnen Module wie Sprachausgabe oder Prellzeile schickt. Und die werden dann dargestellt oder vorgelesen.
Jetzt ist das ja nicht Teil von Windows, diese Software, sondern das ist ein separates Produkt.
Nein, nein, die kostet richtig Geld. Also unter Windows...
Kannst du mal ein paar Namen fallen lassen?
Ja, also der bekannteste ist Jaws. Jaws for Windows.
Also J-A-W-S.
Ja, genau, genau. Der ist eigentlich so der bekannteste. Und der kostet meines Wissens, je nachdem, da wird auch nochmal unterschieden, für welche Windows-Version man das braucht. Also ob man das für 95, 98, Millennium und eine XP Home Edition benötigt oder ob man das halt für die professionellen Windows-Versionen benötigt wie 2000 und XP Pro. Da kostet für 2000 XP Pro, kosten meines Wissens so etwa 2500 Euro. Weil die einfach sehr selten hergestellt werden. Ja, doch, die muss man dann schon bezahlen, wenn man das braucht. Und da hat man eine Sprachausgabe bei. Und die Prellzahlen-Treiber, da hat man vielleicht, da hat man zwar noch keine Prellzeile von, aber die Treiber schon mal dabei. Und unter Linux ist es halt kostenlos. Die Screenreader-Lösung unter Linux, die ich einsetze, Susublinux heißt das, heißt Susublinux, weil das halt von einem entwickelt wurde, der mittlerweile bei Susu arbeitet oder früher schon bei Susu gearbeitet hat und der hat das einfach so getauft. Was nicht heißt, dass es nur auf Susu läuft, ich setze es auf dem Debian-System ein.
Und das dürfte dann wahrscheinlich den üblichen Preis von 0 Euro haben.
Ja, genau, das hat den üblichen Preis von 0 Euro. Richtig, wie man das von der Linux halt gewohnt ist.
Ja, es gibt natürlich auch andere Sachen, aber in dem Fall handelt es sich also auch um GPL-Software.
Richtig, richtig. Wobei man unter Linux auch wirklich noch sieht, dann die Differenzierung zwischen Screenreader und Sprachausgabe. Also da wird unter Linux richtig differenziert. Also gerade Sprachausgabe ist noch ein Problemfeld, was so ein bisschen, ja.
Jetzt ist es, also die meisten Blinden, die ich jetzt so gesehen habe, arbeiten aber eigentlich ohnehin gerne auf der Konsole. Ja, ist das verbreiteter?
Ja, was heißt verbreiteter? Es gibt einfach noch keine andere Möglichkeit, unter Linux, unter X zu arbeiten. Der Screenreader, oder man muss mittlerweile schon sagen, die Screenreader, es gibt nämlich schon mehrere in der Entwicklung. Aber der bekannteste ist eigentlich so Gnupernikus, der im Augenblick entwickelt wird von der Firma Baum. Der ist einfach so, ich habe ihn jetzt getestet vor, naja, vier bis sechs Wochen und der ist einfach im praktischen Einsatz nicht zu benutzen. Man kann, wenn man sich gut auskennt und man ungefähr weiß, was man machen will, kann man eventuell was machen. Also unter Gnome zum Beispiel Nautilus und so, das kann man benutzen, aber schon hier beim E-Mail mit Evolution oder so funktioniert nicht. Und selbst die gnomeigende Paketverwaltung ist mit dem Gnupernikus nicht zu benutzen. Also da sieht man wirklich, die Entwicklung steckt da noch in den Kinderschuhen. Es gibt jetzt, ich glaube, die aktuelle Version ist 1.0 oder so ähnlich, aber da muss einfach noch viel getan werden.
Was heißt es nicht zu benutzen? Also wo hakt es da?
Es hakt einfach da, dass man schlicht und ergreifend das Paket, das man installieren möchte, nicht auswählen kann, weil der Screen wieder nicht anzeigt, welches Paket jetzt ausgewählt ist. Man sieht einfach nicht, welches Paket man ausgewählt hat. Man kann in der Paketliste, die weiß ich wie lang ist, einfach blättern und man weiß irgendwann gar nicht mehr, welches Paket jetzt aktiv angewählt ist. Und das funktioniert einfach nicht richtig.
Okay, habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden? Gnopernicus ist auch ein Screenreader? Versucht ihr jetzt sozusagen das Gleiche zu machen wie Blinux? Oder ist das noch irgendwie ein anderer Ansatz?
Na ja, also prinzipiell versucht macht er das Gleiche, nur eben auf GNOME. Und nur eben hört sich halt gut an, da bei GNOME ist halt die ganze Architektur ja anders. Und der Ansatz ist halt schon ein bisschen, naja, man kann es so direkt eigentlich nicht vergleichen, weil der Ansatz ist einfach ein bisschen anders.
Das heißt, er steigt direkt in dem GNOME-System ein und versucht die Hooks so zu benutzen, die jetzt das Programm-Environment von GNOME liefert?
Ja, also es ist so eine Susublinux, deswegen setze ich ihn gerne ein, kann ich für jede Anwendung ein eigenes Skript machen. Also angenommen, da kommen wir vielleicht später noch drauf auf Soft oder Hardcursor, da merkt man das ganz besonders. Wenn man halt ein Profil für eine Anwendung konkret braucht, dann kann man das unter Susublinux, das ist so extra so entworfen, dass man halt für jede Anwendung ein eigenes Profil laden kann, um was auch eigentlich automatisch mitgeladen wird. Der Ansatz von GNOME Pernikus ist eben jetzt anders. Man möchte jetzt, dass die einzelnen Programme, die einen entsprechenden APIs nutzen und der Screenreader GNOME Pernikus sammelt einfach dort die Daten ein, die dort geliefert werden an den Schnittstellen und verwendet sie dann weiter. Und versucht halt aus diesen Daten möglichst einen sinnvollen Ansatz zu entwickeln, möglichst viel rauszuholen. Das ist natürlich dann das Problem, wenn die Programmierer sich an diese APIs nicht halten, dann kann der Screenreader Benutzer damit auch nicht viel anfangen.
Aber grundsätzlich ist das natürlich schon mal durchaus ein richtiger Schritt, findest du nicht?
Ich finde es in dem Sinne ein richtiger Schritt, weil der Screenreader dadurch schlank bleibt. Er bleibt klein, bleibt relativ schnell, weil es halt nicht auf jede Anwendung angepasst werden muss. Und es ist halt im Moment so, dass es leider noch nicht so richtig funktioniert, weil eben das noch nicht so überall bekannt ist. Aber ich denke, wenn sich die Programmierer da dran halten und das jeder einhält, dann ist es halt auch der Vorteil, dass wenn eine Anwendung erneuert wird, wenn ein Update kommt oder so, und die sich in dem Update auch wieder an die Schnittstellen halten, dann kann der Screenreader-Benutzer alles nach wie vor nutzen. Unter Windows, zum Beispiel unter Jaws, ist es auch so, dass es wie beim Sozoblinux, das halt für jede Anwendung ein eigenes Skript gibt, gibt es dann jetzt, weiß ich, ein Office 2004 oder so, und die haben dann eine Neuerung eingebaut, dann ist das erstmal so, dass das mit Screenreader nicht zu benutzen ist, solange der Screenreader-Hersteller keine Skripts gemacht hat.
Was muss da in dieses Profil, in dieses Skript konkret reingebaut werden? Also was kann man diesen Screenreadern sagen, damit sie es einfacher haben, mit dem Programm zusammenzuarbeiten?
Ja, jetzt machen wir es am Beispiel von Susublinux. Da wird jetzt zum Beispiel festgelegt, also wird ein Hardcursor, ein Softcursor benutzt. Wenn ein Softcursor benutzt, wird das vielleicht erstmals kurz zu erklären, was das ist.
Genau, jetzt müssen die Leute mal die Sache mit den Cursor erklären.
Genau, also der Hardcursor oder auch Systemcursor genannt ist, eigentlich den Cursor, den man auf der Konsole hat und direkt sieht.
Der kleine blinkende Freund.
Ja, genau, auf der Bash zum Beispiel, wird der konkret angezeigt. Und wenn man jetzt einen Softcursor, zum Beispiel der Midnight Commander, der nutzt einen Softcursor, das ist eigentlich nicht der Systemcursor in dem Sinne mehr, sondern da bewegt sich ein Farbrahmen. Es ist glaube ich ein Rahmen, ich habe es selber ja noch nie gesehen, ist ja verständlich. Dieser Farbrahmen bewegt sich dann, wenn man den Cursor bewegt und der Systemcursor bleibt halt an einer Stelle stehen. Und man wählt dann halt seine Elemente mit diesem Farbrahmen aus, mit diesem Systemcursor oder ich sage es auch noch mal.
Ein Overlay, so ein Meta-Cursor, der quasi über den Dingen schwebt, den man positionieren kann, um sich Sachen anzuschauen, unabhängig von dem eigentlichen Cursor, der immer sagt, wo man jetzt schreiben kann oder so.
Genau, genau. Und das Problem ist jetzt eben halt, dass ich den Anwendungen, die er sagen muss, dem Screenreader, jetzt hast du einen anderen Cursor, den du verfolgen sollst. Weil der Screenreader verfolgt standardmäßig immer den Systemcursor. Macht ja auf der Konsole auch Sinn. Ich möchte ja bei einer Eingabe auch sehen, was ich eingegeben habe und nicht, was 17 Teil drüber steht. Das brauch ich ja nicht zu wissen. Also daher verfolgt er immer standardmäßig den System ohne Hardcursor. Habe ich jetzt eine Anwendung, die einen Softcursor benutzt, dann muss ich dem Screenreader mitteilen, jetzt verfolge den Softcursor. Das heißt, hier muss ich schon mal differenzieren. Und die Differenzierung geht sogar so weit, dass ich dem Screenreader sagen muss, also bei dem Softcursor musst du auf folgende Farben achten. Folgende Farben ändern sich und die bilden den System Softcursor ab. Und dann muss das Screenreader darauf achten und verfolgt dann diese Farben konkret.
Okay, verstehe. Also schon noch eine relativ knifflige Geschichte, wo dann die Programme auch entsprechend zuarbeiten müssen, indem sie halt auch konsistent mit Farben zum Beispiel umgehen.
Ja, beziehungsweise das Beste ist einfach, wenn man auf dem Softcursor verzichtet und entwirft einfach alles mit Hardcursor. Da braucht nämlich kein Skript extra her und so, dann funktioniert die Anwendung einfach.
Gibt es denn ein gutes Beispiel, wo diese ganze Integration soweit gut funktioniert? Also wo ist das am besten gelöst?
Das kann ich jetzt so gar nicht sagen. Ich verwende halt viele Anwendungen, die einfach gut zu benutzen sind. Also weiß ich im ICQ-Client zum Beispiel MICQ oder betrachten wir als Mailer MAD oder betrachten wir ja LYNX zum Beispiel oder LYNX, wobei ich LYNX selber nicht einsetze, weil ich ihn einfach nicht mag. Aber gut, das ist halt wieder typisch LYNX-Philosophie. Jeder nutzt das, was er will. Oder IRSI zum IRC-Client oder so. Also das funktioniert eigentlich alles problemlos.
Jetzt hast du ja schon erwähnt, also der Screenreader hat zwei Ausgabemöglichkeiten. Entweder er übersetzt den Text direkt in Sprache und liest es vor. Ist das eigentlich convenient? Ist das irgendwie angenehm, sich das so vorlesen zu lassen? Oder ist es jetzt angenehmer mit der zweiten Methode, mit der Braillezeile zu arbeiten?
Ja, also ich mach das gerne gemischt, weil es kommt halt immer darauf an, was ich mache. Also es ist so, dass ich navigieren, finde ich mit der Braillezeile besser, weil die Sprachausgabe da einfach zu langsam ist. Bis die Sprachausgabe von wegen irgendwie, in welchem Verzeichnis ich bin, weil die Sprachausgabe zum Beispiel, wenn ich in der Konsole einfach mal ein Change Directory mache, ein anderes Verzeichnis, dann ist es ja so, dass die Sprachausgabe dann den ganzen Prompt von vorne vorliest. Also erst irgendwie Username, Rechnername und dann Verzeichnis. Und wenn ich dann im siebten Unterverzeichnis bin, bis die Sprachausgabe hinten angekommen ist, habe ich das mit der Prellzeile wesentlich schneller erfasst. Das ist einfach so wegen der Geschwindigkeit. Mache ich das jetzt aber, möchte ich jetzt mailen und habe jetzt eine längere Mail, die ich mir durchlesen möchte, weil jetzt jemand mir eine Mail geschrieben hat, wo er viel schreibt und so, dann lasse ich mir die lieber vorlesen. Das ist bequemer, wie die mit der Braille-Zeile komplett zu lesen. Also am besten arbeitet man mit allem zusammen, beiden zusammen und verwendet dann entsprechend das, was man gerade braucht.
Wie funktioniert die Sprachausgabe mit verschiedenen Sprachen? Kommunizierst du primär in Deutsch oder hast du auch englische Kommunikation?
Na ja, Kommunikation ist halt unterschiedlich, wenn auch mal Englisch dabei ist, überwiegend Deutsch denke ich. Aber Englisch kann man natürlich nicht aus dem Weg gehen. Es ist klar, man braucht einfach nur eine Mainpage lesen, weil man jetzt irgendwie eine Option von Copy oder so oder Remove oder so vergessen hat. Dann kommt man halt auch an englischer Sprache nicht vorbei. Das ist halt unter Linux ganz normal. Wer kein Englisch da machen will, der darf sich mit Linux nicht beschäftigen. Aber es ist halt so, dass die Sprachausgabe dort, ich hab sie jetzt einfach auf Deutsch eingestellt und ich mühe mich jetzt nicht, um vier Sätze in Englisch zu lesen, die Sprachausgabe umzustellen. Also dann lese ich es entweder mit der Braille-Zeile oder na ja, wie man auch meint. Also das ist mir dann zu aufwendig. Es gibt ja im Moment auch meines Wissens, zumindest, vielleicht bin ich da auch noch nicht richtig informiert, das kann ja durchaus auch sein, es gibt meines Wissens aber noch keine Funktion, dass man jetzt mit einfachem Tastendruck die Sprache von Deutsch auf Englisch umstellen könnte. Unter Windows gibt es ja schon den Ansatz unter Jaws, das nennt sich dann automatische Sprachenerkennung, aber das funktioniert nicht, das war das erste, weil ich abgeschaltet hab.
Ja, das ist eigentlich doof, dass in E-Mails normalerweise gar nicht drinsteht im Header, in welcher Sprache sie geschrieben sind.
Ja, das ist halt... Ja, das mag sein, aber das ist halt das Problem, dass zum Beispiel... Also, unter Windows seh ich es zum Beispiel ganz konkret an Homepage-Inhalten, ja. Da gibt's ja die Möglichkeit, dass man die entsprechende Sprache ausweist konkret. Und der Screenreader macht das... Also, ganz beliebt ist es zum Beispiel ein einfaches Mail-Archiv, was mit Mailman gemacht wurde oder so, wenn ich das lesen möchte. Ist es ja so, dass dann oft der Screenreader jetzt die Header, der E-Mail wie From und Date und so, erkennt er als Englisch und liest es dann in Englisch vor. Aber er kriegt dann nicht mehr den Touch zurück auf Deutsch, sodass er die ganze E-Mail in Englisch vorlesen will. Und ich finde, also, da klingt, wenn er deutsche Wörter mit englischer Sprache vorliest, das klingt schlimmer wie andersrum.
Ja, kann ich mir vorstellen.
Also daher habe ich das gleich deaktiviert.
Da wahrscheinlich die meisten unserer Zuhörer mit solchen Geräten nicht arbeiten, sollten wir das vielleicht auch nochmal kurz vorstellen. Hier dein Breyer-Display, das ist so ein Gerät, das hast du unter deiner normalen Tastatur stehen. Also eine Zeile mit diesen Breyer-Stiften, die von unten hoch und runter geschoben werden können. Ein Element sind, glaube ich, acht Punkte, wobei sechs für das Zeichen sind und zwei für den Cursor.
Wie viele davon gibt es? Nein, nein, nein, so ist das nicht. Oh Gott. Nein, das sollte ich gleich aufhören. Nein, nein, nein, jetzt nehme ich das mal in die Hand. Nein, also erstmal ist es so, dass die Zeile 40 Zeichen breit hat, also 40 mal diese 8-Punkte-Elemente nebeneinander. Ein Element, wie gesagt, hat 8 Punkte, also 2 nebeneinander und 4 untereinander. Und man kann gar nicht sagen, es gibt die Möglichkeit zu sagen, ok, der Cursor soll nur die 2 untersten Punkte sein. Aber das habe ich gar nicht so eingestellt. Also ich habe zum Beispiel eingestellt, der Cursor soll alle 8 Punkte sein. Das heißt, wenn alle 8 Punkte gleichzeitig hochkommen, ist das der Cursor. Und es ist halt deswegen 8 Punkte, weil 6 würden nicht ausreichen. Weil in der normalen Blindenschrift, Punktschrift ist es ja so, dass man sich dort auf ein 6-Punkte-Feld beschränkt. Da hat man aber das Problem, wenn man jetzt ein großes A zum Beispiel schreiben möchte, dann würde man in der normalen Blindenschrift erst ein Zeichen setzen, was jetzt kommt, wird groß geschrieben. Und dann kommt halt das einfache A. Und das wäre natürlich am Computer. Also da habe ich ja viele Großbuchstaben und so. Wenn ich nur 40 Zeichen habe, dann ist das ja sehr ärgerlich, wenn ich dann schon vier Wörter, die groß geschrieben sind, in einer Zeile habe, dann habe ich ja schon vier Zeichen, die ich eigentlich verschwenden würde. Daher nimmt man zwei Punkte mehr und dann werden die unteren beiden Punkte verwendet, um das entsprechende Großschreibzeichen zu schalten. Ich glaube, das ist sogar nur der untere rechte Punkt. Ich bin da so drin im Alltag, dass ich das gar nicht mehr genau merke. Und bei Zahlen ist es halt ähnlich. Da wird ein Punkt dazu geschaltet, wenn man die Zahlen darstellt. Also weil in der normalen Blindenschrift würde man ein Zeichen setzen, das heißt so, jetzt kommt die Zahl und dann würde im nächsten Feld die Zahl kommen. Und das ist ja natürlich auf dem Computer auch ärgerlich. Man braucht ja dann nur mal vier Zahlen zu schreiben, dann hat man schon wieder vier Zeichen, die zu viel wären.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie diese Escape Codes, die man ja auch von Terminal-Kommunikationen erkennt, die ja dann auch einmal früher schon die Bandbreite geraubt haben. Diese Geräte sind ja nicht ganz billig. Was muss man so zahlen auf einem freien Markt für so eine große Fiduza?
Ja, so eine 40-stellige Preilzeile, wie ich sie hier habe, die kostet zwischen 4.000 und 5.000 Euro. Oder auch teilweise bis zu 6.000 Euro. Und wenn man jetzt eine nimmt, es gibt hier die auch noch mit 80 Stellen, dann kostet sie einfach doppelte, also 10.000, 12.000 Euro. Für eine 80-stellige Preilzeile kann man schon durchaus normaler Preis. Es gibt die auch noch mit 20, damit die halt billiger werden, hat man auch kleinere gebaut mit 20 Zeichen und 15 Zeichen und so. Aber das ist dann meiner Meinung nach ein bisschen zu klein. Mehr als 80 nicht, weil das wäre nicht zu bezahlen. Also wir würden schon 20.000 Euro oder 24.000 Euro ausgeben. Außerdem ist das ja auch eine Platzfrage. Jetzt 80 Zeichen, das macht noch gehen, das ist dann ein bisschen breiter wie die Tastatur. Aber wenn man dann 160 Zeichen oder so macht, dann ist das Schreibtisch zu klein.
Was macht die Dinger so teuer?
Ja, die Prelelemente, die einzelnen Prelelemente sind in der Herstellung sehr, sehr teuer, weil die sehr aufwendig gefertigt werden müssen. Da steckt sehr viel Technik dahinter, dass wenn man auch mit dem Finger drüber fährt, dass die dann, wenn sie nach unten gedrückt werden, auch wieder rauskommen und so. Und dann ist es ja so, dass wenn man viel damit arbeitet, ist es ja so, dass man auch ständig ein bisschen Staubpartikel oder so am Finger hat, die dann halt auch irgendwann da dran hängen bleiben und so. Deswegen müssen sie dagegen ja auch ein bisschen resistent sein. Und so ein Prelelement mit so 8 Zeichen kostet etwa in der Herstellung zwischen 40 und 50 Euro. Also, dass man da mal eine Vorstellung bekommt. Eins und einziges Element.
Okay, dann summiert sich das natürlich schon ganz gut. Dann kommt natürlich noch das restliche Gerät dazu und die Software. Wie schließt man so ein Brei-Gerät an den Rechner an?
Ja, also meins lässt sich anschließen ausschließlich über Seriell. Die neueren, es gibt jetzt schon welche über USB oder halt auch über Bluetooth. Das Problem ist halt einfach, ich sag jetzt deswegen Problem, weil das bei der Hardware-Erkennung in der Tat ein Problem ist. Bei den USB-Geräten haben die Herstellerfirmen nichts anderes gemacht, wie ein Seriell-to-USB-Converter eingebaut in die Hardware. Und das Problem ist halt auch gerade unter Linux habe ich schon, es gibt schon so ein paar Skripte, die die Prellzeile automatisch erkennen. Und da ist halt gerade das Problem, wenn der USB-Seriell-Converter auf dem Linux nicht erkannt wird, kann die Zeile dahinter auch nicht erkannt werden. Und das ist in der Tat ein Problem. Und ich habe jetzt einen USB-Seriell-Converter gefunden im Handel, der gut funktioniert. Mit meiner Zeile, aber das ist nicht immer so. Und deswegen ist das eigentlich sehr, sehr aufwendig und nicht unbedingt gut.
Wäre eigentlich wünschenswerter, wenn die Dinger wirklich nativ USB sprechen und auch wirklich sich verhalten wie ein Hallo, ich bin ein Breihe-Gerät.
Richtig, richtig. Aber das ist halt wieder wahrscheinlich eine Kostenfrage oder so.
Wahrscheinlich die Angst davor, die Software auch wirklich mal anpassen zu müssen, auch wenn das letztlich alles viel einfacher wäre dann.
Ja, es wäre halt auch einfacher, weil USB mittlerweile ein derartiger Standard ist. Das, ja, gut, jetzt die ersten Bluetooth-Geräte, die es gibt, es werden jetzt immer mehr. Ja, die sind anscheinend gut. Ich hab keine Erfahrung mit gesammelt, weil ich selber ja eine Prellzeile nicht als Bluetooth-Gerät habe.
Wundert mich jetzt so ein bisschen, dass da Bluetooth schon verwendet wird, wo noch mal, wo USB noch nicht mal richtig genutzt wird. Bietet das jetzt irgendwelche Vorteile da, ohne Kabel zu sein?
Naja, der Gedanke war halt, schlicht und ergreifend geht man mit Notebook auf Reisen. Notebook und Prellzeile. Und man dann Kabel dazwischen spannen will und so. Viele Firmen haben dann schon so kürzere Kabel mitgeliefert, die dann, weiß ich, nur 20 cm lang sind, damit man da keinen Metakabel hat, der überall rumliegt oder so. Das ist natürlich der Gedanke, der liegt da natürlich nahe, wenn man sich dann mit dem Notebook und einer Prellzeile in die Uni setzt oder irgendwo anders hin auf den Kongress geht oder so. Das liegt natürlich da nahe, dass man so wenig Kabel wie möglich braucht. Da ist der Gedanke schon durchaus vertretbar.
Eigentlich bräuchtest du ja nur ein Breihegerät mit WLAN, was dich eigentlich mit deinem Rechner über das Netz verbindet. Dann hättest du ja eigentlich alles, oder?
Ja, theoretisch schon. So habe ich mir noch gar keine Gedanken gemacht. Das ist natürlich richtig. Das ist durchaus...
Ja, mal ein interessantes Hacker-Projekt, weil dann bräuchtest du es noch nicht mal, dein Notebook rumzuschleppen. Wenn du jetzt auf den Kongress bist, stellst du das Ding einfach ins Nock, ins Regal wie so ein Server und kannst das dann komplett aus der Ferne bedienen. Natürlich nur, wenn das WLAN funktioniert.
Na ja, gut, die Bedienung ist halt immer... Da bräuchte ich halt noch eine passende WLAN-Tastatur. Das ist natürlich klar.
Na ja, das wäre halt das normale Reihegerät. Aber den müsste man dann natürlich irgendwie... Ich meine, dieses Bluetooth-Gerät war ja letztlich auch nicht...
Ja, mir nützt ja nichts, nur was zu lesen. Ich will ja auch eine Eingabe machen.
Ach stimmt, ja, der muss auch noch auf die Tastatur.
Ja, es gibt halt schon so Geräte, die hergestellt werden, die dann zusammen... Die sind dann wie so ein kleiner Computer, da ist dann die Prelzeile unten drunter fest und die haben dann eine kleine Tastatur drauf und dann kann man Eingaben tätigen und so. Und die haben dann, weiß ich, zwei MB intern Flash-Speicher oder so. Da kann man dann was ablegen. Aber ich persönlich, viele sagen, ah, das ist toll und gut und ich hab ein kleines Gerät, das ich mit auf Reisen nehme und so. Das ist nicht groß, aber ich persönlich halte davon nicht viel. Weil es ist einfach nicht zu erweitern, wenn ich jetzt ein Notebook habe mit Prelzeile und sag einfach, das Notebook ist mir zu langsam, es ist viel zu wenig Speicher drin. Also was will ich damit? Ich hab jetzt ein neues Windows oder ich hab jetzt einen neuen Film bekommen oder einen neuen Musiktrack oder so. Der passt nicht mehr auf den Speicher. Es gibt ein neues Format, weiß weiß ich. Das Notebook, das tu ich einfach meinem Bruder schenken, weil der immer meine alten Sachen nimmt und kauft mir da einfach ein neues. Und dann kann ich das genauso an die Prelzeile anschließen und vielleicht mit dem Konverter oder so. Aber ich bin relativ, habe ich die Möglichkeit, das zu erweitern, relativ einfach. Das ich sonst nicht habe.
Und so, das ist natürlich jetzt nicht so dein Thema, aber vielleicht sollte man das nochmal erwähnen. Das war ja auch Teil des Vortrages auf dem Kongress. Für die Leute, die jetzt nicht vollständig blind sind, sondern die nur eingeschränkte Sehfähigkeit haben, gibt es natürlich auch noch andere Methoden.
Ja, die könntest du vergrößern. Da gibt es die Möglichkeit, das zu vergrößern. In der grafischen Oberfläche gibt es die Ansätze, schon zum Beispiel Knob Hernikus als Screenreader hat auch ein Magnifier-Interface dabei, das eine entsprechende Vergrößerung machen soll. Unter KDE gibt es meines Wissens die Möglichkeit, den Mauszeiger zu vergrößern, dass man dann besser sieht, wo die Maus sich jetzt befindet. Was ich so mitbekommen habe, haben ja auch viele Menschen, die der Sehens mächtiger sind als ich, Schwierigkeiten, die Maus zu finden, manchmal.
Oh ja, ich mach zum Beispiel meine Maus auch größer. So viele Pixel kann man echt schnell mal ins Rotieren.
In KDE gibt es die Möglichkeit, den Mauszeiger zu vergrößern. Ich glaube, weiß ich nicht genau, ob man Schriften schon vergrößern kann. Was aber auch für viele Sehbehinderte ein absolut wesentlicher Aspekt ist, das meist noch wichtiger ist, wie jetzt die Vergrößerung, das ist einfach, den Kontrast zu verändern. Also Hintergrundfarben und so, damit es einen stärkeren Kontrast gibt. Das ist für viele sehr, sehr wichtig. Und da weiß ich im Moment nicht genau, wie die Fortschritte da sind, weil es einfach nicht mein Fachgebiet ist. Aber die Entwicklungen gehen jetzt halt in die Richtung. Beim KDE wird jetzt, ich glaube in der Version 4, sollte auf jeden Fall eine etwas durchbrechendere Entwicklung gemacht werden.
Man hat überhaupt das Gefühl, dass Accessibility im weiteren Sinne ein Thema wird, dass es also immer eine größere Rolle spielt. Nicht nur, weil jetzt die Behörden schrittweise natürlich auch die Vorschrift bekommen, ihre Webseiten und vielleicht auch andere Tools entsprechend anzupassen. Das ist natürlich auch sehr wichtig. Wir hatten da vorhin schon mal kurz drüber gesprochen, dass, nein, das stimmt gar nicht, das hatte ich in dem Vortrag gehört, dass es natürlich auch für die Berufschancen entscheidend ist, wenn man jetzt irgendwo in der Firma arbeiten möchte, wo Linux eingesetzt wird, dass man da eben als Blinder auch die Möglichkeit hat, genauso mitzuarbeiten.
Richtig, das ist ja auch ein wesentlicher Punkt. Unter Windows ist es halt so, man bekommt seinen Screenedress, seinen Jars und das wird sowieso alles vom Arbeitsamt bezahlt und so. Daher ist das eh alles kein Problem. Aber unter Linux ist es halt so, dass es einfach da noch nicht viel gibt. Auch wenn man dann 3000 Euro bezahlen würde, man hat deswegen trotzdem nichts. Und das ist ja natürlich auch eine Firma, die umstellt auf Linux, weil einfach Windows zu teuer wird in der Wartung und so weiter. Da ist es natürlich so, was macht man jetzt mit jemandem, der blind ist? Und wenn es jetzt darum geht, einfach bei einer Firma hinzugehen, sagen sie ja schön, guten Tag, ich bin blind und ich möchte bei euch arbeiten. Und die Firma sagt dann, ja, wir haben jetzt auf Linux umgestellt. Gibt es denn da was, womit sie arbeiten können? Und ich sage dann, klar, ich habe nichts zu machen und ich kann damit nichts machen und so. Und dann sagt die Firma, dann ist es natürlich auch schwieriger, da den Arbeitsplatz zu bekommen. Das ist natürlich klar. Die Entwicklung geht jetzt halt in die richtige Richtung. Man muss halt warten, was jetzt die nächsten Jahre zeigt. Aber ich denke, die Entwicklung ist da. Und naja gut, ich denke, warum auch Accessibility noch ein wichtiges Thema geworden ist, es wird zwar auch immer besser, aber es gibt hier immer mehr mobile Endgeräte, die einfach auf Web-Inhalte zurückgreifen oder auf andere Inhalte zurückgreifen, die einfach noch Accessibility-mäßig aufgebaut sein müssen. Also wenn man dann mit dem Handy und man lädt dann auch aufgrund der relativ langsamen Internetanbindung, es hat ja nicht jeder U-TMS, dass man dann einfach noch nicht schnell genug an die Inhalte kommt und einfach auch die Inhalte nicht vernünftig dargestellt werden können. Ich denke, das ist auch ein wesentlicher Punkt, warum es dann auch attraktiv wird, die Seiten bei dir frei zu gestalten.
Das stimmt. Die Erfahrung hab ich auch schon gemacht. Wir hatten ja gerade die ersten Jahre im Internet, als dieser ganze Hype ausbrach und toll, und jetzt muss alles noch bunter sein, und die Seiten wurden immer schwerer und furchtbarer, und es sah alles irgendwie ganz fancy aus, aber das war's dann auch, und benutzt waren sie überhaupt nicht. Und jetzt erst letzter Zeit setze ich ja dann auch so dieser Grundgedanke durch, dass so schlank daherkommt doch einfach deutlich mehr Sex-Epil hat und ganz nebenbei eben auch einfach sehr viel besser zu benutzen ist. Das hat natürlich mit den mobilen Geräten zu tun, aber eben auch, dass es ja vielleicht auch manchmal ganz brauchbar ist, sich auf ein paar Standards zu einigen.
Richtig, richtig.
Es gibt jetzt auch eine ganze Menge Projekte, oder eine Menge ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber zumindest gibt es einige Projekte. Wir hatten ja auch schon jetzt ein paar genannt, die sich konkret diesem Problem, Accessibility und natürlich auch besonders Blinde und Linux, andienen.
Ja, richtig. Da gibt es viele Projekte, das ist richtig. Das Problem halt bei den ganzen Projekten ist, also es gibt ja auch mehrere Screenreader, zum Beispiel für die Konsole. Da gibt es Braille TTY oder da gibt es Festival als Sprachausgabe oder da gibt es dann diesen Desktop YASA oder wie der heißt. Oder da gibt es Emacs Speak und da gibt es ganz, ganz viel. Das Problem ist einfach, das sind alles einzelne Splittergruppen. Es gibt da niemanden, der so richtig sagt, okay, also setzt euch mal an einen Tisch und entwickelt was Vernünftiges. Da hat jeder halt seine einzelnen Insellösungen, die für jeden vielleicht entsprechend seine Arbeitstechnik gefunden hat, gut sind. Das möchte ich gar nicht bestreiten. Aber es gibt halt viel, aber nichts Vernünftiges in dem Sinne. Und das ist halt ein Problem. Und wir jetzt, das ist auch jetzt ein Projekt, das wir gegründet haben, Linaccess. Unser Linaccess-Projekt hat sich halt zur Aufgabe gemacht. Und das ist halt unser Ziel, dass wir dann versuchen zu sagen, okay, wir zeigen euch das und das für Lösungen. Gibt es, die sind so und so, die funktionieren so und so. Aber es ist auch sinnvoll zu sagen, okay, also Entwickler kommt mal her, setzt euch mal hier hin. Wir müssen uns jetzt mal einigen. Das funktioniert so nicht mehr. Wir brauchen jetzt etwas, was vernünftig läuft und was vielleicht einzigartig sein könnte.
Wann habt ihr das Projekt gestartet?
Ja, wir haben das Projekt, naja, wann haben wir es gestartet? Eineinhalb Jahre, zwei Jahre vielleicht. Wir sind jetzt dabei, das ein bisschen umzustrukturieren. Wir gründen gerade einen EV, damit es halt auch einfacher ist, jetzt Mitglied zu werden und so. Und damit wir halt auch besser auf Kongressen und so da sein können. Wir sind als nächstes auf dem Linux-Tag in Wiesbaden. Das ist eigentlich so unser nächstes jetzt im Mai, dass so das was ansteht. Und ja, dann mal schauen. Das ist halt, ja.
Ja, schau ich gerade auf die Webseite. Einer der bekannteren Namen ist Klaus Knopper, der bekannt ist als Hauptautor von Knoppix.
Richtig, richtig.
Welche Rolle spielt er da in dem Zusammenhang?
Ja, er ist auch in unserem Projekt Mitglied. Und er ist jetzt im Moment maßgeblich an der Entwicklung einer deutschen Sprachausgabe beteiligt, die in der GPL laufen soll. Das ist halt so ein Unterprojekt von uns, wo wir auch noch dringend Unterstützung brauchen. Gerade bräuchten wir unbedingt einen Sprachwissenschaftler, einen Linguisten, der uns sagen kann, welche, weil das alles gar nicht so einfach ist, welche Silben wir in Deutsch aufnehmen müssen, um halt, wenn man die aneinanderreit, dass man eine vernünftige deutsche Sprache hinbekommt. Das ist unser Hauptproblem, auch im Augenblick. Weil das Problem ist halt, es gibt zwar deutsche Sprachausgaben, zum Beispiel die in Prola, aber die steht unter einer Non-Commercial-Lizenz und so, die dürfen wir nicht einfach auf einer Knoppix oder so frei mitgeben. Und das ist halt ein Problem, weil wir würden gerne schon, das ist eigentlich unser Hauptprojekt, das wir im Augenblick verfolgen, daraus resultieren halt einige Unterprojekte. Wir wollen halt eine barrierefreie oder eine Accessibility-Knoppix entwerfen, wo dann so ein bisschen, ja, menübasierend die Anwender darauf vorbereitet werden. Das ist natürlich jetzt unser Hauptaugenmerk erstmal auf blind und zähbehindert, aber es könnte ja auch durchaus sein, dass für neue Anwender, die nicht erfahrene Anwender sind, die zu Linux kommen, die aber vielleicht ältere Rechner noch haben oder überhaupt keinen Bock haben auf irgendein buntes Rumklicken vom KDE oder GNOME, die dann vielleicht einfach eine menübasierte Führung haben möchten in der Konsole mit Endcursors basiert. Das soll dann so aussehen, dass man dann einen Menüpunkt hat wie, weiß ich, Internet und darunter gibt es dann die Möglichkeit, WWW mit Lynx oder WWW mit Lynx oder so ähnlich soll das aufgebaut sein.
Also im Prinzip reden wir ja auch schon um jetzt gar nicht mehr darum, Software zu bauen, damit man mit der normalen Software auch umgehen kann, sondern schon eher dahingehend sehr einfach, vielleicht nicht sehr einfaches Software, aber sehr einfach zu bedienende Software zu erreichen, die Blinde oder eben auch andere Leute, die in irgendeiner Form eingeschränkt sind in der Nutzung des Computers. Das muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Behinderung sein, sondern das kann ja auch im Auto unterwegs, während man aus dem Flugzeug mit dem Flugzeug Fallschirme springt oder so. Da möchte man ja auch noch mal kurz bei Amazon. Und die Sachen kommen normalerweise zusammen. Habt ihr schon mal überlegt, oder habt ihr da Kontakte vielleicht mit Universitäten, die sich jetzt in diesem linguistischen Bereich beschäftigen, Kontakt aufzunehmen?
Es ist oft so, dass das, was wir brauchen, gibt es eigentlich selten. Wir könnten auch jemanden gebrauchen, nicht nur einen einfachen Linguisten, sondern er sollte vielleicht auch schon mal was von Computern gehört haben. Und das ist natürlich eine seltene Mischung. Man mag es eigentlich gar nicht glauben. Viele sagen jetzt, na, es gibt doch schon Sprachausgaben und so, die ganzen Telefonschleifen und so, was über Asteroids läuft und was es da alles gibt. Aber das Problem ist halt, das ist alles sehr begrenzter Wortschatz. Das handelt sich vielleicht um 200, 300 Wörter oder so. Das ist alles aufgenommen, automatisiert und so. Das ist halt keine richtige Sprachausgabe. Das gibt es nur ein paar Wortfetzen und so. Aber es gibt halt da noch nichts richtig. Richtiges Sprachausgabe. Und das ist halt das Problem, dass es an solche Leute ziemlich schwer ranzukommen ist. Wir haben uns schon mal umgehört jetzt hier. An der FU hatte ich mal angefragt, da gab es nichts. Bekannt ist zumindest, uns hat auch schon mal irgendwie, der Klaus Knopper hat auch schon mal in der Universität Kaiserslautern meines Wissens angefragt und so. Das ist halt nicht so einfach, dass man da drankommt. Aber vielleicht hört das ja jemand und hat Interesse. Der soll dann einfach mal auf unsere Homepage schauen und soll einfach mal eine E-Mail checken. Wir freuen uns dann gerne.
Genau, ihr habt aber auch noch andere Kontaktaufnahmemöglichkeiten. Unter anderem gibt es auch einen festen Kanal auf IRC-FreeNodeNet.
Richtig, richtig. Allerdings muss ich da bedauern, ist im Moment relativ wenig dort los, weil wir einfach auch noch nicht so viele Mitglieder sind. Wir sind im Moment so zwischen 15 und 20 Leute. Also ich würde sagen, die beste Kommunikation ist entweder eine E-Mail an kontakt.linaccess.org oder vielleicht auch eine E-Mail an mich oder so. Ich leite das auch weiter. Zumindest kann man dann sicher sein, dass man eine Antwort bekommt, weil ich eigentlich dort ein aktives Mitglied bin. Oder halt auch einfach, ich halte auch ab und an in Berlin einen oder anderen Vortrag. Vielleicht hat man einen passenden Vortrag, der einen interessiert. Also jetzt am 10. Mai halte ich bei New Thinking in Kreuzberg ein. Vielleicht hat man da noch mal eine Anlaufstelle. Da kann ich dann auch noch mal konkret Fragen vor Ort beantworten. Oder man kann dann auch da in Kontakt kommen.
Gibt es eine spezielle Veranstaltung, die sich diesen Themen widmet in Deutschland? Messen oder ähnliche Events, wo sowas zum Sprache kommt?
Ja, was heißt, der Sprache kommt? Es gibt die Side City in Frankfurt. Das ist irgendwann Mitte oder Ende Mai. Das ist also eigentlich eine Ausstellung, die sich am Blinden und Sehwinter der Menschen richtet. Das ist im Airport Hotel da. Und da wird halt vieles vorgeführt. Da kriegt man dann nur ganz viele Braillezeilen zu sehen. Und viele Sprachausgaben hört man reden und so. Und wir wissen noch nicht, ob wir da einen Stand haben werden. Aber das ist eigentlich so die Messe für Blinde und Sehbehinderte jetzt konkret. Ansonsten ist mir eigentlich wenig bekannt in der Richtung.
Wie schreibt sich das?
Side City. Ich glaub S-I-G-H-T und dann City. Meines Wissens. Ich glaub, das gibt's auch.de. Ansonsten wird das, glaub ich, veranstaltet von der Firma Baum. Also einfach Baum wie Baum draußen halt, baum.de. Und ich glaube, das sind die Hauptveranstalter. Das ist eine Hilfsmittelfirma und ich glaube, das sind die Hauptveranstalter von der Messe.
Die machen ja auch diese Software, die eine.
Ja, das Knobherne-Kurs, richtig. Die ist dann unter Baum.ro zu erreichen, weil die Entwickler sind in Rumänien billiger als in Deutschland.
Ich seh grad hier, sidecity.net in Frankfurt.
Ich hab schon lange nicht mehr auf die Seite geguckt.
Ja, das mit den Endungen, das ist ja auch immer so ein Spaß für sich. Was mich halt immer interessiert ist, was kann man jetzt gerade entweder als Computerexperte oder generell auch als Nicht-Blinder für die blinden Szene oder für das Vorankommen der Software, die da richtig funktioniert, was kann man da am besten zu beitragen?
Na ja, gut, das hängt erstmal von den Fähigkeiten ab und von dem Wille. Man kann auf jeden Fall erstmal zu unserem Linaccess-EV kommen. Wenn man programmieren kann, haben wir genug Arbeit, können wir den einspannen, dass er irgendwelche Endcursors-Menüs entwirft oder vielleicht ein Software ein bisschen was umschreibt oder anders schreibt oder so. Da finden wir schon irgendwas. Im Moment fehlen uns auch ziemlich viele Programmierer. Wenn man das Programmieren nicht so mächtig ist, da gibt es ja auch viele, die können dann helfen, sei es, dass wir vielleicht mal mitfahren zu einer Messe oder so zum Linux-Track mitkommen, mal einen Stand betreuen oder so. Ja, sowas machen, da halt unter die Arme greifen. Oder wir suchen auch Leute, die einfach dokumentieren können, die einfach jetzt ein Programm getestet haben oder so auf verschiedene Kriterien hin, die man festlegen müsste, wo man sagt, okay, wie ist das Programm verständlich oder so. Oder wir suchen auch Leute, die sagen, okay, ich kann besonders gut Deutsch und besonders gut Englisch. Ich könnte jetzt euch bereit helfen, hier mithelfen, eure Homepage mit ins Englische zu übersetzen. Wir sind nämlich eigentlich, haben wir uns aber bestreben, die Homepage zweisprachig aufzuziehen. Weil die meisten Accessibility-Entwickler auch und so, das ist eigentlich im englischsprachigen Raum eigentlich wesentlich ausgebreitet da in den USA zum Beispiel. Also von Sam zum Beispiel Peter Korn ist dort ein ganz, ganz konkreter Name, der ist da sehr beschäftigt und der kennt sich damit auch sehr gut aus.
Peter Korn, ist das nicht der mit der Kornschel?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Aber der Peter Korn ist da eigentlich sehr, der kennt sich sehr gut aus. Was wir auch noch vorhaben, aber das ist ein Vorhaben, das bedarf sehr, sehr großer Organisation. Da müssen wir auch noch sehen, dass wir um Spenden kommen und sonst was kommen. Also das, wir haben aber vielleicht vor, das könnte vielleicht in zwei, eins, zwei Jahren was werden. Wir würden gerne, wahrscheinlich in Berlin, gerne mal ein internationales Accessibility-Treffen veranstalten, wo wir dann auch die Leute wie Peter Korn oder so aus den USA heranschaffen, dass man sich vielleicht mal an einen Tisch setzt, an einen großen, dass man dann vielleicht mal so ein paar Workshops macht oder Vorträge hält, kleine, da wo man mal einen kleinen Ist-Stand feststellt, wie ist es jetzt, was gibt es in der Welt, und dass man das ein bisschen internationaler aufzieht, dass man da den Blick ein bisschen schärft und dass man dazu vielleicht noch zusammen festlegt, was kann man jetzt noch verändern, in welche Richtung müsste man sich jetzt bewegen und so, dass man vielleicht da was... Aber das ist so eine Zukunft, was wir vielleicht mal demnächst machen wollen. Aber da muss erst unsere Vereinsgründung durch sein. Und da müsste man sehen. Nur da kommt es dann halt auch auf Hilfe an. Am besten Leute aus Berlin oder so, die ein bisschen vor Ort sind, weil wenn nur ich hier bin und das alles organisieren soll, alleine von hier ist ein bisschen schwierig.
Das ist klar. Ja, es gibt natürlich auf jeden Fall auch die Möglichkeit, interessante Vorträge zu dem Themenfeld für den nächsten Kongress einzureichen. Das ist auch dann in Berlin. Das Thema haben wir auf jeden Fall auch gerne dabei. Und ansonsten, wenn ihr die Möglichkeit habt, wenn ihr was mit Sprachausgabe, Linguistik zu tun habt, dann überlegt doch mal, ob das nicht vielleicht eine Beschäftigung für euch wäre.
Ja, wir würden uns freuen.
Genau, und das Ganze dann unter linaccess.org. Seid ihr auch auf dem Linux-Tag jetzt in Wiesbaden?
Ja, ja, hatte ich ja gesagt. Das haben wir vertreten, da haben wir einen Stand. Und wir werden auch Workshops anbieten. Und ich werde da einen kleinen Vortrag machen, das jetzt nicht unbedingt was mit Barrierefreiheit zu tun hat. Aber vielleicht, deswegen ist es vielleicht ein guter Punkt, jemand, der sich das interessiert, ich werde was machen unter dem Titel Arbeiten mit Texttools und Krummel.
Was ist denn das?
Krummel oder GRML, das ist eine Knoppingsdistribution, die nur auf Texttools läuft. Die haben zwar auch einen Window-Manager mit bei, aber das ist eigentlich ein kleiner, also kein KDE, kein GNOME. Die spezialisieren sich hauptsächlich auf Texttools. Also da ist dann die Z-Shell zum Beispiel drauf und nicht die Bash und so. Und Mud NG ist drauf und so. Also ganz viele Texttools. Und die richtet sich eigentlich so an Administratoren und an Texttool-Users. Und da hatte ich jetzt halt, wann war denn das? Auf dem Linux-Sach in Chemnitz hatte ich halt mit dem Entwickler dort gesprochen, mit dem Michael ProPoke, oder wie der heißt. Und ja, da habe ich mir die angeguckt und war davon sehr positiv beeindruckt. Und da werde ich, denke ich, unter dem Titel mal einen Vortrag machen, Arbeiten mit Textools und Krummel. Vielleicht interessiert das den einen oder anderen, der mit Textools mehr zu tun hat oder so. Der kann dann gerne vorbeikommen.
Ja, genau. Und ich sehe gerade, und das Krummel, das basiert auch auf Knopfbicks.
Ja, genau, genau, genau. Ist zwar ein bisschen anders, die nehmen ein anderes Fallsystem, also nicht mehr C-Loop, aber das ist ja nur so am Rande.
Okay, und die nächste SideCity da in Frankfurt sehe ich gerade vom 17. bis zum 19. Mai im Sheraton Airport.
Genau, dort im Hotel, richtig. Wobei da noch nicht sicher ist, ob wir da vertreten sind.
Okay.
Das kann ich jetzt noch nicht sagen, soweit konnten wir mit der Planung erst mal haben wir genug mit dem Linux-Tag zu tun gehabt. Wir machen dir alle bei hier auch noch was anderes.
Ja gut, aber okay, ihr seid auf jeden Fall auch herzlich eingeladen, auf den Kongress euch auszubreiten. Ja, jetzt haben wir eigentlich eine ganze Menge Sachen hier durchgehauen. Gibt es noch irgendetwas, was wir vergessen haben, was wir auf jeden Fall noch erwähnen sollten von deiner Seite her?
Wüsste ich jetzt eigentlich so nicht. Vielleicht, wenn es irgendwie konkret Fragen gibt, dann einfach nochmal an mich wenden. Vielleicht einfach eine E-Mail schreiben oder so.
Genau, oder allgemein auch Chaosradio at ccc.de, wenn es um Chaosradio auch im Besonderen geht. Und da könnt ihr auch E-Mails zur Sendung als solcher hinschicken, falls ihr euch mit dem Linaccess-Projekt auseinandersetzen wollt. Dann war das nochmal welche E-Mail-Adresse?
Ja, das ist contact.linaccess.org. Linaccess, also linaccess.org.
Genau. Oder ihr nutzt auch unsere Feedback, Telefonnummer, Audio-Kommentare zu hinterlassen, wie ihr möchtet. Alle verschiedenen Möglichkeiten stehen zur Verfügung. Ich persönlich, du hast ja gesagt, du hast mit Podcasts selber noch nicht so viele Begegnungen gemacht. Ich denke, dass das ein wertvolles Medium sein kann. Gerade für die Blinde-Szene, weil man ja hier eigentlich nichts anderes machen muss als zuhören. Da braucht man keinen Screen-Rider. Da kriegt man sozusagen schon alles vorgelesen. Das werden wir mal verfolgen, wie das da weitergeht. Und ich habe mich selber noch nicht mit beschäftigt, inwieweit es spezielle Blinden-Podcasts gibt. Wenn ihr da was wisst, was vielleicht interessant ist, dann würde mich das auch interessieren. Alles nach Chaosradio at ccc.de. Ja, so, dann bleibt mir jetzt eigentlich nichts mehr, als mich herzlich zu bedanken bei dir, Sebastian.
Ja, auch danke. Und ich denke, es war vielleicht ein guter Einblick, und dass man sieht, was sich die nächste Zeit entwickelt. Ich denke, wir werden da schon was hinbekommen.
Ja, dann sag ich mal Tschüss. Und wir hören uns sicherlich bald beim nächsten Chaosradio Express.